[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com we're gonna start today with
a media story I'm gonna present to you
today the epitome of right wing media
dishonesty and distortion and it's gonna
be specifically talking about the
economy and employment numbers so last
week as often happens in the first few
days of a new month we get the jobs
numbers from the previous month
we got them late last week from June
there were totally unremarkable job
numbers for June more or less a
continuation of similar numbers that we
saw what we saw under President Obama
213 thousand jobs were added during the
Obama administration 214 thousand jobs
per month were added that was during
Obama's second term the unemployment
rate went up slightly to 4% very small
change I've been telling you for years
and years how the unemployment rate is
calculated it's been calculated the same
way for a very long time very often when
you have low unemployment numbers under
a Democratic president you will see
Republicans say when people stopped
looking for work they're no longer
counted as unemployed so the number
doesn't mean anything and then all of a
sudden when a Republican has low
unemployment numbers Republicans seem to
completely forget that they were
critical of how that number is
formulated when it was Barack Obama or a
Democrat what we do often see
Republicans talk about when there is a
Democrat in the White House is the
number of people who are not working
sometimes this is used interchangeably
with the labor force participation rate
and I've been telling you for a year
after year after year that the raw
number of people that are working or the
raw number of people that are not
working the labor force participation
rate they are very often misleading
sometimes useless and almost 100 percent
of the time
those numbers are used for political
gain by whoever is looking to distort
the reality of the economy it
communicates almost nothing about to the
about the economy to say X number of
people are working and the headline that
Drudge Report right-wing propaganda
sludge report ran when the June numbers
came out red record 155 million employed
this is presumably the number of people
with jobs in the United States I am also
going to show you the headline from the
same website Drudge Report on March 8th
of 2013 when Barack Obama was president
the headline read eighty nine point
three million not working the number of
people not who are unemployed but people
who aren't in the labor force right so
when Drudge said eighty nine million not
working that included retired people
that included full-time college students
it included stay-at-home parents who
don't need to work because they are
well-off financially and what you need
to understand to realize how you are
being manipulated or there are attempts
to manipulate you with these numbers
remember that the population of the
United States has been going up forever
at many times in American history there
have been record numbers of people
working at the same time that you had
record numbers of people not working you
can display either number to make a
political point and case in point as I
told you a month ago maybe it was two
months ago
there are also a record number of people
not working right now just as right now
we have if you believe the numbers from
Drudge Report more people than ever
working because there are more people in
the United States than ever before the
numbers mean nothing
and following Drudge Report right-wing
media just jumped all over this thing as
if it was some miracle and I hate to
break it to them but sometimes record
numbers of people working isn't a
positive thing and I'll explain the
percentage not the number
the percentage of people over 85 years
of age 85 or older working today is very
high
back in 2006 before the the recession
2.6 percent of those 85 or older were
working 2.6 percent today you have
almost twice as many people over age 85
working they're part of the victorious
great economy of record numbers of
people working right well hold on let's
just think about it for a second some
people who are over age 85 were working
because they want to some people over
age 85 are working because 85 year olds
are slightly healthier today than they
were in 2006 on average although there
hasn't actually been that big of a
change but overall when you read that
part of the record number of people
working is a higher than ever rate of 85
plus year-olds you have to think about
it and realize wait a second there's
more eighty five year olds than ever
working because they have to because
wages are stagnant because cost of
living goes up as wages are stagnant and
Pat this is how the right-wing media
spins these bogus narratives they put up
a number record 155 million working it
means nothing and it becomes the talking
point for the month of July yeah I
remember shortly after the Trump
administration began Sean Spicer was
saying that the president didn't believe
the strong jobs numbers under Obama
right but now the Trump is president he
obviously does believe them but I mean
that that was at least delivered
somewhat tongue-in-cheek I guess it's a
lot of epoxy when he said that it wasn't
clear whether it was like a 90 percent
joke or a 50 percent joke but there was
like some understanding of the political
nature of the numbers it was the Drudge
Report they're trying to deceive you and
sightings actually succeeded with many
of us they do and unfortunately the
audience that it is being delivered to
is eating it up like it is being just
ladle fed to them and it's it's any
small amount of critical analysis
applied to that tells you that it is
merely spoon feeding nonsense to a
hungry audience that's all it is the
Trump administration is now admitting
that they've lost track of about
percent of the parents of the toddlers
who have been separated from their
parents so kids of all ages have been
separated from their parents at the
border looking specifically at those
five years of age and younger the Trump
administration said during a conference
call with both reporters and a judge
that they are unsure about the
whereabouts of one in five sets of
parents of the toddler's separated and
it's not clear if and when they are
going to be reunited a US District Judge
Dana
Sabra was on this call Friday this is
related to the deadline the
administration was given a deadline of
tomorrow July 10th for reuniting these
separated toddlers with their parents
and originally the Trump administration
said they were gonna meet that deadline
they then backtracked now they're going
to miss the deadline and the new number
is that roughly half of those under five
will hopefully be reunited by tomorrow's
deadline and Alice Olsteen from Talking
Points Memo has been following the court
cases around this and she tweeted as
this was developing the Trump
administration just told a federal judge
that 19 parents of children under five
years old have already been deported
they are arguing that they shouldn't
have to reunite them with their kids the
ACLU is pushing back the kids under five
are in the u.s. at these internment
style detention centers the parents are
gone the parents are no longer in the
country what do you do next
this is a humanitarian crisis it's a
moral crisis it's a legal crisis in the
sense that are there going to be any
repercussions to anybody for not
reuniting these kids with their parents
that's not being discussed also not
being discussed is the financial aspect
here it's not cheap to keep Hiep these
kids after you've deported their parents
why would you do it even if you lack
empathy for the kids or
parents even if you don't have a
compassionate bone in your body what
about the cost of this why not send the
kids back with the parents and it's the
party supposedly a fiscal responsibility
it's the president who campaigned as
Trump did on being fiscally responsible
what is fiscally responsible about this
and of course the truth is fiscal
responsibility is a propaganda line it's
never actually a priority it's something
you say and when we actually get down to
it and we think about going beyond now
just the the child migrant crisis the
blue state subsidized the red states red
states lack infrastructure they lack
education they lack access to health
care because their economies are by and
large not working and without the blue
states like California New York
Connecticut Massachusetts New Jersey
Illinois Minnesota actually is is one
that pays in much more than they get out
federally without those blue states
places like Mississippi and Alabama and
Virginia although Virginia's kind of
purple New Mexico West Virginia Alaska
Indiana a lot of these places would be
screwed full-stop like I don't have to
qualify it in any other way but you know
who does win hugely from these
detentions of the kids of the adults who
ever it's the private detention
companies it's the banks that own huge
interests in those private detention
companies it's a huge score for them and
part of this is immoral policy part of
this is incompetence they've literally
lost track of what's going on and they
are not only unable to get everyone
reunited at this point it's not even
clear it's legally possible because the
parents of some of the kids are gone pat
they're not even in the United States
you're not going to reunite them you're
simply not and I'm curious to see
ultimately what happens with the
deadline and are there any repercussions
the administration already saying well
half of them simply aren't going to be
reunited our goal now is 50% will there
be any consequence to the Trump
administration if you think the answer
might be yes let me know how because
I'm not optimistic about that send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show we'll take a quick break and be
back after this huge news weekend that I
want to tell you about the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com let's say hi to a few people
actually I'll say more than I will say
thank you to Joseph
Isaiah coos today's new member of the
day also want to say thanks to Mark
Danielson mark has been with us since
2010 eight years of membership that's
two full presidential terms of
membership for mark Danielson thanks to
Joseph thanks to mark join them by
signing up for a membership at WWE
pakman.com you can also become a patron
it's only a dollar a month minimum very
low entry to this what we call what what
they caught mean I didn't come up with
it what is called patreon go to
patreon.com/scishow
ok I I think it's time to not sugarcoat
the problem that we may have called no
voter turnout in November and just kind
of tell it like it is I've been talking
about voting in the midterms we have a
lot of different forms of activism that
we are working on in order to resist the
Trump regime but one of the primary ones
that I've been espousing for a long time
is you've got a vote in November right
there's nothing else if you've been
activated by the election of Trump if
you're horrified by the embarrassment of
the United States's reputation around
the world if you're just concerned about
a particular issue like the possibility
as legal analyst Jeffrey Toobin said of
abortion bans in 18 to 20 states over
the next couple of years on the basis of
Donald Trump's soon-to-be announced
Supreme Court pick whatever you're doing
in addition to voting you've got a vote
okay and when we talk about specifically
November of 2018 I've told you about the
historically low turnout in midterm
elections that means your vote
sort of matters even more right if the
turnout is expected to be lower on a
mathematical level your vote matters
even more I've talked about the
importance of voting to interrupt the
Trump agenda we've talked about the
Supreme Court implications I've said
before does
matter what Robert Mulder comes up with
if you have a Republican House and
Senate between 2018 and 2020 or 19 and
21 as it is effectively you're not going
to have consequences to Mulder's
investigation we've talked about that as
well Pat you've got to vote for that
reason yeah in history would tell us
that the Democrats will do well in the
2018 midterms but history also told us
that Hillary Clinton would win the 2016
election exactly right the economy was
relatively strong and Obama was popular
but that didn't happen it did not happen
and fortunately in the middle of 2017 we
had high enthusiasm high engagement in
terms of being engaged and even a few
months ago in April of 2018 several
polls still showed that there was an
enthusiasm gap in favor of Democrats
depending on the poll maybe not quite as
big that enthusiasm gap is rapidly
shrinking and potentially fading and
this is a disaster and I have been doing
whatever I can to explain why you must
vote in November of 2018 I've challenged
this false logically fallacious idea
that because one vote never changes in
elections results it's not worth voting
I won't do that again but I've been
talking about that and I've been
explaining why all of this matters and
over the weekend I got it I got an email
from longtime viewer Stephanie who's
been a great supporter of the show by
the way
for many many years who said hey David I
want to do my part to get people to vote
can I sponsor some half price
memberships for people who are working
on getting people to vote in November
and Stephanie and I went back and forth
and we sort of came to the reality that
in some way it would have to be on the
honor system right like how can we
demonstrate that someone has earned a
half-price membership there's really no
way to do it so here's what we're going
to do okay if you're doing anything to
help take down this right-wing regime in
November you can get a half-price
membership if you want it Stephanie will
pay for half of your membership
memberships are normally 60 bucks for
the year all the member benefits that
you get normally 60 bucks for the year
Stephanie will pay 30 you pay the other
30 just write in and tell me what you're
doing for the midterms if you're phone
banking great if you're helping people
register great if you're just badgering
your friends to vote that's fantastic
and honestly Stephanie
even said with midterm election turnout
so low as I mentioned she said David if
people write in and simply say they're
gonna vote in the midterms and that they
want a half-price membership she's
willing to sponsor that as well so it's
on the honor system if you don't need
the discount and and you would be okay
paying full price don't ask for the
discount the idea is to expand access
and bring more people into what we're
doing for a good cause really a crucial
cause if you want the half-price
membership go to david pakman.com slash
contact tell me what you're doing for
the 2018 midterms and that you want one
of these half-price
Stephani memberships and I'll send you
the coupon code it's the honor system
and Stephanie's okay with that yeah
we're doing everything we can to get
people engaged here yeah our thanks to
Stephanie I love this contest especially
because I think I'm in need of some hope
and yes inspiration and I think this
will provide that to me Pat's gonna get
fourteen hundred half-price memberships
on the basis of I guess his
participation on the show and that
that's that's what Pat's piece is half
price membership just right in david
pakman.com slash contact tell me what
you're doing to help with the November
midterms and I'll send you that coupon
code no limit Stephanie could end up
having to pay for a lot of $30
memberships here because she said she
believes that she can cover as many
memberships as we might get from and all
1,400 of mine too that's us she's in for
many many tens of thousands of dollars
on that basis okay the world's two
biggest economies are the United States
and China the United States and China
are also now in a trade war thanks to
Donald Trump and what I want to prepare
you for is a bunch of the stuff that you
buy regularly getting much more
expensive as you might remember the
Trump administration previously
announced tariffs on China those went
into effect on Friday and there are new
tariffs now on thirty four billion
dollars in Chinese products China
immediately retaliated with thirty four
billion dollars in tariffs on American
products five hundred and forty five
different goods targeted by China long
list beef seafood dairy not concerning
for the vegans I guess but also farm
goods including this is going
beans are actually a big part of what's
going on with the tariffs and vegan Pat
is gonna be very very concerned about
that
cars another tariffed item this isn't
good for American workers the Chinese
people buy a ton of stuff from Nike and
Apple and Starbucks vehicles from
General Motors a lot of the
manufacturing for the American companies
does happen in China but these are in
the end American companies that are
going to be hit so on the one hand
you've got Chinese tariffs on the US
that's going to hurt American workers
then on the other hand American tariffs
on Chinese stuff are going to make
Chinese products more expensive for
American workers this is not good for
American workers Trump promised he was
just going to be great for American
workers and this is just the first 34
billion from Trump we know that there is
potentially another 16 billion
kind of in process and Trump has
threatened as much as 450 billion
dollars in tariffs and I've been ranting
and raving to you about the short-term
impacts of these tariffs for a while you
know them by now the question I'm now
thinking about and I was reading about
over the weekend is how does this end
what's the endgame here Trump claims
that the tariffs are because China is
unfair to the United States on trade and
is stealing intellectual property okay
those are specifics so are you putting
the tariffs in and then negotiating to
fix those problems do Trump's advisors
even agree on what the solution to those
problems would be hint they don't agree
on what the path forward is and just as
sort of like a vignette of what is going
on American businesses that deal in
soybeans for example soybeans are a big
part of how these tariffs are just gonna
be absolutely disastrous soybean farmers
in the US and the Midwest are already
delaying buying equipment and making
investments in their own businesses so
the way it works is Trump tariffs China
China tariffs American soybeans the
American soybean farmer says well I'm
going to delay
a John Deere tractor so now Trump's
China tariffs hurt John Deere in the
United States as well and meanwhile the
exact same thing is happening with
Canada Canada has done the same they
have now made effective twelve point six
billion in tariffs on the u.s.
retaliating because of American tariffs
on Canada exactly who we want to be
hostile with Canada right that's really
gonna work out well for us and I'll
remind you Trump said trade wars are
good and they're easy to win well then
win it I'm ready to win this thing Pat
well how long is that going to take yeah
you were talking about the endgame I
really wonder what Trump thought these
other countries would do just to roll
over and take these tariffs I know he he
wanted to make it up as you know because
he thought there were these trade
deficits with all these countries that
we had and he was just making up for
those but those countries don't see it
that way and they don't in particular we
have a trade surplus with them and let's
talk about Canada as an example here's a
wake up call at this point that we all
need we are talking about can Democrats
take over the House and Senate in
November if so can Trump be defeated in
2020 we'll be able to get back on track
it's gonna take a long time to fix the
damage that has been done to these
relationships with countries like Canada
as Pat is pointing out the meaningless
executive orders can be undone the
positions that Trump just isn't filling
you can get those filled pretty quickly
as soon as you get a competent
administration but the damage that's
being done at the geopolitical level and
to the environment by this
administration is going to take a long
time to undo in the best case scenario
and if Democrats don't win in November
and particularly if Donald Trump wins
re-election in 2020 we're talking about
possibly decades to undo the damage that
is being done here decades you know what
the end game is with the tariffs please
let me know because I've not been able
to get any straight answers from anybody
at this point if an investigation were
about to end would the guy running the
investigation hire even more prosecutors
you tell me Donald Trump has been
telling us for a long time now that
we're almost at the end of this thing
the Moller investigation is just about
to end we heard last year that it would
be over by thanks
giving 2017 when it didn't end we were
told it would be over by New Year's Day
January 1 2018
that didn't happen throughout early 2018
and even over the last month or so we
have been told time and time again that
it's it's almost over we're really
almost at the end here and we learned
over the weekend that special counsel
robert muller has hired even more
prosecutors to work the investigation
prosecutors as the name implies
prosecute you hire them if you want them
to partake in prosecution and
prosecution related activities and the
report is that robert muller is going to
be expanding that team and potentially
even stepping away from some of the
casework I've said it before and I'm
going to remind you if the investigation
ended today the prosecution of the cases
we already have could take years if we
have another six to 12 months of
investigation and further indictments we
are looking at this stretching into
Donald Trump's second term for sure or
potentially even into well depending on
whether Trump wins or loses the next
president's first term so far we have 20
indictments and five guilty pleas at the
end of the day I don't pretend to know
what will happen I get emails from
people Pat we say David why are you so
sure that XYZ is going to go down or
that Trump's inner circle is going to
end up in prison I've never said
anything like that I don't know what's
ultimately going to happen what I do
know is that number one there's no
evidence or indication that this
investigation is almost over that's
number one number two we know that
Watergate took years that means that
this may take years if this is bigger
than Watergate it could take
significantly longer than Watergate and
this gets us right back to don't beat me
up Pat but I've got to mention it this
gets us right back to voting in 2018 and
2020 I was thinking over the weekend why
might someone want to vote in November
well as I mentioned earlier don't hurt
me I know I mentioned this midterm
turnout is often low that means your
vote if you choose to vote matters more
House and Senate control is key too
stopping the Trump agenda taking over
the House and Senate in 2018 better
positions you to win in 2020 but related
to the Muller investigation Muller can
say whatever he wants he can issue
whatever findings he wants to issue
Republicans are not going to act on
Mulder's findings Muller has been
smeared and discredited and while it's
bogus it works with the right
it works with Republicans and that is
going to provide cover for Republicans
when Moeller finally tells us whatever
it is that he found Republicans will say
these are political reports we can't act
on what Muller found because Muller is
compromised which is why Democrats must
take over the House and Senate so that
they will act on whatever Moeller's
findings are yeah and it's also becoming
increasingly clear that a sitting
president cannot be indicted
so if Trump is going to face any
criminal repercussions for what he may
have done we have to come through
impeachment after yeah yeah and that's
not gonna happen if Democrats don't have
control of the House or Senate no
question about it no question about it
so whatever you care about if it's
seeing consequences to the Moller
investigation or seeing the tariffs that
are destroying farmers who by the way
are mostly still supporting Trump even
though Trump is hurting them it's
stunning cognitive dissonance that's
going on whatever is important to you it
all leads back to voting in November
what's the date I should so I would be
able to say November 6th is it the 6th
don't hold me to that yeah I don't know
what they in the first week of November
of 2018 quick break we will be back
after this discuss this or any stories
of interest from today's show on the
David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD i.t the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to be joined today by Joe
McConnell who's a research professor at
the desert Research Institute in Reno
Nevada he's an expert in ice core
studies of past climate and human
impacts on the environment and there's
no shortage really of different areas
where we could we could talk about ice
studies Joe but let's just generally
first of all talk to us about what types
of information about the past can we
glean from studying ice yeah so well
first thanks for having me on and
secondly so so yeah we Amit are all
around us or little particles and
droplets in the air and those droplets
get blown around the earth and deposited
through precipitation or onto the ice
sheets and glaciers around the world and
so we can go back by by drilling into an
ice sheet we can go back and study the
chemistry of the atmosphere the study
and study the chemistry of precipitation
and go back you know hundreds of you
decades or hundreds of years or
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of years and that can tell us a lot of
things about climate you know sea ice
and things like that about forest fires
about volcanoes and then in this
particular case about anthropogenic
impacts or pollution so how can we
determine when a time wise a portion of
an ice core is from in other words is
there some equivalent to like rings on a
tree to determine age or how would we
know that yeah it's great question the
the so depends on the ice score in this
particular study that we've we've done
in Greenland recently the annual layers
meaning the amount of snow that falls
each year is about let's say a eight
inches of snow eight inches of water
equivalent so about let's say thirty
inches of snow is one year at the
surface and and essentially
all the things that we measure in the
ice core have a seasonal variation so
it's just like exactly actually it's
it's like a tree ring in the sense that
we can count annual layers so we start
at the surface when we drilled the ice
core and then we just go backwards in
time counting one year two years three
years four years in this case it's all
the way back to about 1100 BC so about
3,100 years long is that about the limit
to which ice can be useful in figuring
out elements of what was going on in
history timewise about 1100 BC well you
know it's an interesting question they
you can in theory of course you can go
microphone back much further we have ice
core records that we annually layer
counted in my group as far back as
30,000 years in Antarctica in terms of
the human impacts we'd like to go back
to say four or five or six thousand
years before present you know so maybe
three or three to five thousand years BC
but the problem is the quality of the
ice so this may be a little more than
you want to hear and in Greenland for
instance where she drilled these ice
cores on the ice sheet divided and
that's where we ideally would like to
drill them at about about about 1500 BC
or 1200 BC that time that corresponds in
that time you enter something called the
brittle ice zone and that's where the
ice is so over-pressured and the glacier
that as soon as you bring it to the
service it explodes are nearly explodes
and it cracks and fractures like crazy
and so the reason we chose the depths we
did in this ice core was because we
wanted to get to the very top liberal
ice go as far as we could into the
glacier and still get really good
samples what can't ice core studies tell
us that maybe at one point we thought
could I mean obviously they're not going
to be able to predict the results of
sporting events so I don't mean like a
full list of what we can't glean from
ice cores but in the sort of universe of
the types of data that maybe we would
like to or thought we might be able to
get from ice what does it turn out we
really can't learn from ice cores well
so so one thing to keep in mind is we're
a long way from this source and
princesses in Greenland or Antarctica
where the best ice cores come from
you're a long way from the
that you're likely to want to study so
you can understand resolution whether
there's transport of that pollutant to
to the ice sheet a good example of
something we hope to get and so far
haven't been able to get is copper
pollution from these ancient economies
in Mediterranean and the reason is
because there's so much there are other
sources of copper things like volcanoes
forest fires commented us things like
that that are blowing around in the
atmosphere and that creates a background
noise level if you will a background
variability and to see a something like
economic signal we need that signal to
be above the background sufficiently
that we can say absolutely that's humans
that are causing that lead is a nice
example because let has very low
background levels in the natural
environment but the pollution signal was
quite large and so that's why we were
able to use lead in this particular case
yes so let's now talk about lead and
this idea of being able to make
deductions about what was going on
economically based on that and
specifically you've been looking at the
the Roman economy so let's get sort of
into this a little bit what was the role
of lead in that economy such that it
would even be interesting to look at now
so there are a number of reasons
I guess chief among them is that silver
ores and the Romans ran their economy
Earl especially during the Empire and
the Republic ran on silver largely and
that's what they made their coinage from
the Denarius and so they needed to have
new just like when the US was on the
gold standard or the silver standard we
needed to have supplies of new metal
coming in for our coinage and so the way
the Romans got that was by mining lead
silver ores and so when they wanted the
silver they would smelt and collate and
so forth the ores and in the process in
order to get the silver in the process
they would release a lot of lead the
atmosphere you know they were I'm not I
don't mean to say they weren't
interested in lead but lead was not
their primary objective it was in the
silver we think that was the primary
objective so you can imagine that the
supply of new metal into the economy is
a very good indicator of history
that economy because the economy relies
on that new metal so generally speaking
the idea is that there would be sort of
a correlation between the we might call
it like production or GDP of ancient
Rome that we could deduce from the
amount of lead that has that appears in
the ice cores that you study is it more
or less that type of correlation yeah I
think it's probably so we're using it as
a in our in our world we would say a
proxy of economic activity over all
economic activity and the reason that's
true besides this new metal idea is that
in order to mine and smelt light or LED
silver ores at this level of scale now
you need to have a lot of governmental
organization you needed to have slaves
unfortunately to do the mining you
needed to have the ability to D water
mine so logistical it was a pretty big
deal and required a lot of organization
you can imagine a lot of government
services and organization an army and so
forth to to be able to do this
production at this level and so you know
when when things weren't going well that
those logistic logistical resources you
might say fell apart a little bit and
that's why we we think this is a good
indicator another reason why we think
this is a good indicator of the overall
economy have the results from studying
the ice confirmed or changed our
understanding of how the Roman economy
was doing at different points in time
well it's interesting because you know
as an ice core guy the I wasn't that
aware of what the historians were doing
with the data prior to a few years ago
and these colleagues these ancient
historians and historian sorta economic
historians contacted me about this but
it turns out that there were 18
a total of 18 points over this same
three thousand year period roughly that
had been measured before 18 points over
3,000 years with each point representing
two years and this was done in the 1990s
again using a Greenland ice core and
historian because a lack of other
information we're using those eighteen
points to argue things like whether the
Roman Republic was a more efficient
economically or whether the Roman Empire
was more efficient economically and you
can imagine political scientists had
discussed this and so forth for a long
time fine decades if not centuries what
they inferred from the previous 18
points was that the Roman Republic was
more efficient and in fact are much more
complete data instead of 18 points we
have nineteen twenty one thousand sorry
twenty one thousand points from that we
can very clearly see that the most
sustained and stable period of leaded
pollution and therefore the Roman
economy was during the Roman Empire and
so that's a fundamental difference in
historical understanding of what was
going on if we can I'd like to talk
about a couple other areas of ice
studies and some of them are relatively
topical we hear that in you know
corporate media the conventional wisdom
is that we are rapidly losing ice in
general on our planet we have also heard
what some call the sceptical position or
the climate science denying position
that there's actually an accumulation of
ice taking place at the poles both can't
be true right I mean this this this is
an objectively knowable fact it sounds
like to me absolutely and and from a
scientific perspective from an
observational perspective there's no
question that ice is disappearing
there's no question that the planet is
warming up and driving that loss of ice
I mean absolutely no question you can
argue about things like sea ice because
the sea ice is sea ice in Antarctica for
instance is highly cyclical so in I'm
meaning there's a 20 to 30 year period
in the in the content of sea ice around
Antarctica and right now we happen to be
or at least in the last few years we
happen to be in a period where sea ice
in Antarctica was increasing but again
that sea ice not land ice sea ice
doesn't change sea level because it's
floating in water it doesn't change sea
level but land ice if you move water
from the land ice reservoir into the
ocean back into the ocean to where it
originally came from then you'll raise
sea level so that's I think where the
confusion comes from and there's no
question that glaciers and ice sheets
the vast majority of
are rapidly disappearing and I should
add that they're disappearing in a way
that we would predict meaning that
climate our understanding of climate
science and glaciology and so forth we
would predict the loss that we're seeing
so it's perfectly consistent with the
observations are perfectly consistent
with global warming theory okay now as
far as indicators of the impact of
humans on our planet's climate that we
can see through ice one of the
criticisms of temperature records for
example direct temperature records that
we hear is that they go back to 1910
1920 1880 you know it's just not a lot
of time speaking in terms of the age of
our planet when it comes to ice what
kind of a window does ice give us both
quantitatively in terms of number of
years and you may have already answered
that when talking about you know a
couple thousand three or four thousand
years total and qualitatively about our
impact on the climate yeah so so yeah
observations as you mentioned
observations have gone back let's say
reasonably extensive observations have
gone back about a hundred years maybe
120 years something like that
ice cores can take us back you know as
far as 800,000 years of course the
resolution that you get on the record is
very for 800,000 years ago but the kind
of thing that I study typically I mean I
do work on on old ice as well as young
ice but the whole not a second here the
age of the ice that that you were where
we would say we have a pretty high
resolution high quality record I'm at at
least 120 hundred and forty thousand
years it depends on whether you're
talking about Antarctica or Greenland in
terms of temperature you know
temperature is one of those things is
still a little bit tough to get or to
understand from an ice core we typically
use water isotopes in combination with
measurements of actually the temperature
of the ice so you can imagine if you
have a piece of ice sitting there and
you above it then slowly I think Richard
alley my colleague at Penn State uses
the analogy of a turkey in the oven and
how I put a frozen turkey in the oven
then the heat
propagate into the frozen turkey and
melt it over time and that's kind of
what we do in an ice sheet is we you
know when we measure the temperature of
the ice itself and from that we can use
models to tell us what the temperature
of the air about it was absolutely
fascinating work out of curiosity do you
spend a lot of time in cold places so
that the ice remains ice while you're
studying it I mean I did is that like a
day-to-day thing about your job yeah
sure I do go to Antarctica and Greenland
and other places quite a bit to collect
ice cores particularly earlier in my
career and now I tend to send my grad
students for postdoc to where this and
then also another one I another place I
send my grad students to post Docs is
into the freezer here when we're
analyzing analyzing the ice we typically
are in the cold room about minus 20
centigrade so about let's say their
degrees Fahrenheit more or less and and
spending all day and there's pretty
owners all right so like Boston in
January basically is what it does what
it sounds like but for more time yeah Jo
McConnell research professor added a
desert Research Institute in Reno Nevada
thank you so much for talking to us
about your work today thank you very
much
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
not that we needed more evidence to
question the mental stability of the
president but he spent his weekend
obviously at one of his golf resorts
this time the one in New Jersey spent
his weekend tweeting about various
conspiracies and of course about
Hillary's emails he's been president for
a year and a half and he's still
tweeting about Hillary's emails and it's
very quickly becoming like having
conspiracy theorists Alex Jones as
president of the United States Donald
Trump tweeting rife with the bizarre
grammar and capitalization that we've
become accustomed to over the weekend
quote the rigged witch-hunt originally
headed by FBI loverboy Peter S for one
year and now 13 angry Democrats should
look into the missing DNC server crooked
Hillary's illegally deleted emails the
Pakistani fraudster uranium one Podesta
and so much more
it's a Democrat con job I don't know
where to start okay so let this is like
under 50 words I think I counted it's
like 47 words here's what he has
squeezed into this small number of words
which is actually a sort of literary
achievement to squeeze this much
nonsense into only 47 words he calls the
Russia investigation of witch-hunt no
evidence of that that's a popular one of
for Trump the Peter asks that he refers
to his Peter struck this is the guy who
was an FBI agent didn't head the
investigation he was one of many people
that were involved and once his
anti-trump text messages came to light
he was removed from the investigation in
fact the handling of the Peter Strock
situation was done 100% correctly and is
not not indicative of any wrongdoing by
the FBI Trump then talks about 13 angry
Democrats that's Trump claiming that 13
Democrats at the FBI run the entire
investigation which is court of course
not true and as you probably know Robert
Muller the guy in charge he's a lifelong
Republican Trump references a missing
DNC server there are missing records of
all kinds on both Democratic and
Republican sides not really a unique
thing we have
problem in our government with records
going missing talks about Hillary's
emails Hillary lost almost two years ago
I don't know why he's still talking
about Hillary's emails he even said that
even though his priority was going to be
to lock her up that it's not actually
going to be so why he's talking about it
I don't know then he mentions this
Pakistani fraudster now that you may not
have heard about that refers to an
individual whose last name is a Wan
who's connected to a government IT
situation a Wan was a former IT aide for
Debbie wasserman-schultz
and he made unauthorized access to the
servers of the House of Representatives
but again it has nothing to do with the
Trump Russia investigation whatsoever he
brings up uranium one that's of course
the completely debunked conspiracy
theory that there's different versions
of it but one is Hillary illegally gave
all of our uranium to Russia and there's
actually even crazier versions of that
one even Shepard Smith on Fox News
debunked it and then he just says
Podesta that's not really anything
that's just referring to John John
Podesta as a person he refers to John
Podesta but that's not really anything a
single 47 word tweet with eight
distortions or straight-up conspiracy
theories well David the president is
busy he works something like 20 hours a
day he barely sleeps yes you know ending
the Korean War on Monday and
resuscitating the coal industry on
Tuesday he doesn't have time to
fact-check he doesn't have time to
spellcheck you're expecting too much
from him this is what happens when you
have an Alex Jones presidency or some
guy who watches Fox News in the Oval
Office and it's not how a stable genius
behaves and if you're Justin Trudeau or
a Manuel McCrone or Angela Merkel Angela
Merkel what do you think when you see
this stuff and actually we know what
they think and we know that Trump
doesn't care what they think because
he's alienated them completely
what does Putin think when he sees this
stuff he thinks everything's going
exactly to plan and is very very pleased
okay I've got a new story for you that
sounds like an old story but it's not
it's just that it happened yet again we
have new all-time hottest temperature
records that were set all over the
northern hemisphere over the last week
climate scientists
are reporting that the heat that we've
had over the last week I experienced it
in New York City when I was there for a
wedding I told you about that a few days
ago this is part of many Northern
Hemisphere all time high temperatures
for this time in the year it's not just
the United States in the u.s. we had all
sorts of highs Denver hit an all-time
high on June 28th for June 28th but it
also includes Oman it includes Northern
Ireland it includes Georgia the Republic
of Georgia not the state the US state of
Georgia Armenia all over the world
record high maximum temperatures and
record high minimum daily temperatures
Quebec has had deaths linked to the
heatwave the UK has had the warmest June
since records started being kept more
than a hundred years ago northern
Siberia has been setting temperature
records and the climate deniers actually
you know I don't even know that I should
call them climate sceptics anymore I was
gonna say deniers or skeptics they're
really just deniers they will say this
is cyclical it's too short a period of
time to notice real trends a hundred
years 200 years of temperature data
that's not really anything and of course
it ignores a ton of other data right it
ignores that climate change models as
Joe McConnell told us earlier on the
show predict exactly this not just
rising temperatures overall but erratic
high and low temperatures and it's not
just temperature because we are also
able to figure out the amount of co2 in
the atmosphere we can track sea-level
rise we can track all sorts of different
data and this is why Trump is extra
dangerous right now because we can fix
some of his misdeeds like I said earlier
we need on this issue a president who
wants to double down on science and
double down on engineering and
climatology not someone who wants to get
us out of the Paris climate deal and
double down on conspiracy theories and
self-aggrandizement and I want to remind
you I think we should remind ourselves
of this tweet every time we talk about
this issue Trump tweeted once quote the
concept of global warming was created by
and for the Chinese in order to make
American manufacturing non-competitive
this matters wanting to revive the coal
industry
when this is going on matters and I
wonder how much longer will I be
reporting to you even more record high
temperatures and record low temperatures
and melting land ice
how much longer will I and many others
be reporting this stuff until we
actually take action because it's been
years and years and the window to act is
getting smaller and smaller and I spoke
to somebody over the weekend it was
actually kind of depressing Pat he was
saying to me you know I I am an
environmentalist I really care about
this but he's thinking of changing his
mentality altogether to just forget
about the environmentalism and the
activism because he's realizing we are
doing irreversible damage and either
we're gonna find a way to live on other
planets once we destroy this one or were
not and I can't do anything about it
this was the realization this person
came to it was incredibly fatalistic and
depressing but in some way look at
what's going on we we need to be acting
now and we are not yeah a lot of the
stuff we can't reverse I mean I guess if
you want to remain a little bit
optimistic there are things like solar
geoengineering we could look into or
maybe even terraforming another planet I
don't know but I don't want to be too
fatalist about it but if the plan is we
have to terraform planets which would
take a very very long time is it really
going to make a difference if you want
to drive the SUV do you just drive the
SUV because no matter what we're
destroying it I'm not advocating for
this view I'm telling you what someone I
spoke to over the weekend at an
extraordinarily warm outdoor event by
the way was telling me and I don't
that's not how I view issues but he
started to make some sense not in terms
of what I would like but in terms of the
pragmatic realities write to me and tell
me why I'm wrong can we still undo the
damage that we're doing we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p got a very nice
voicemail from a teacher over the
weekend take a listen to this hey david
this is tim from Bloomsburg Pennsylvania
I'm a 25 year old middle school teacher
and I just made my first patreon pledge
yes as this show emphasizes critical
thinking and media literacy something we
desperately need in our classrooms
around the country thank you keep up the
great work and I'll be a supporter for
years to come thank you so much
and David of course all right
very very nice voicemail the miniseries
are going really well the critical
thinking miniseries was extraordinarily
well received the pseudoscience
miniseries so far is well received
although we actually do have in our
audience and it is a little bit
depressing to me some pseudoscience
believers who have surfaced and started
to say no psychics are real astrology is
real etc that's a little bit
disappointing to me but overall the
pseudoscience mini-series is being but
very well received and we're gonna keep
doing it we're gonna keep doing it and I
appreciate the support I guess we could
have anticipated that just because many
of these pseudo Sciences are widespread
yeah they're among our audience of
course but around among the general
public generally some people are gonna
believe in astrology other people are
gonna believe in chiropractic medicine
sure the whole game whoa pet that was
now as a pet cat just stepped in it
shots fired across the bow yeah just
wait pat may not be able to survive this
week on the David Pakman show after
mentioning chiropractic okay on the
bonus show today we will not be talking
about chiropractic arts or Sciences
depending on your perspective on that we
will be talking about what's going on
with the Thai cave rescue and we will
talk about why does that get so much
attention when the thousands of African
children dying every day of hunger and
get almost no attention in Western media
I know it's cliche people are gonna hear
me say that and they'll say David again
with the African children dying of
hunger we shouldn't care about the
African children but I think it actually
illuminates some very interesting media
biases that we should all be aware of we
will also talk about Filipino President
Rodrigo Duterte saying he will quit his
job as president if somebody can prove
God exists via a selfie a selfie would
be the vessel through which he would
want that proven we will also report to
you about ID Adam the man who questioned
a black woman's right to use a pool he
has lost his job after what is widely
agreed to be although not by everybody
not by maybe the race realists but it's
mostly consensus that his questioning of
a black woman's right to use a pool was
racially motivated we will talk about
those three stories and more on today's
bonus show don't miss the
bonus show the bonus show at this point
is it's exciting and titillating to
members and patrons of all ages become a
member at WWJ join pakman.com or become
a patron at patreon.com slash david
package quite a mouthful we'll talk to
you on the bonus show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you